my my channel has a lot of names
Gary Glitter old Harris kyun Huntley are
you the Terminator sir
you the Terminator Steve you know Muslim
today you camera on wheels
I suppose them noise okay we get
attacked okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna let the footage speak for so
cuz that's all I needed from you thank
you Steve it was a pleasure yeah did you
hear it clearly yeah he said no Muslim
was attack so who ever wanted to do is
just go to Steve yeah okay because I
believe Steve is one of those people who
has hate towards Islam a this Brahma
here he got attacked today yeah okay
we've got the footage I'm gonna pray to
you right now you see on the screen here
we go to Steve just imagine a Muslim
going to a Christian or a Jew or a Hindu
or whether maybe I'm going bang stuff in
him across his face this guy Steve would
do backflips from here all the way up
there yeah you did backflips that
there's no tomorrow so you see the
hypocrisy this is what's happening guys
they have hatred and even when it's with
our prayers that they stock not because
it violates from this the park rules
the only reason because they hate us
simple as so as why you guys of course
we respect it he came and slapped you
yeah whoever this guy was you know he's
an Islamophobe yeah okay okay so for why
noise look for example you could have
easily defend yourself yeah because
somebody is attacking you you can say
you have a right even defend yourself
here
why did you know Oh first of all because
this is speakers corner yeah here so we
have to respect the laws of speakers
photos yeah secondly because my religion
teaches me they have to have mercy on
people yeah now I could've well done
more than what he did to me Jimmy Morris
I'm a big big guy zone I can take a
punch interior
so this guy came to me and he's been
making threats to me how did it's not
after we basically there was couple of
those two guys having a bun oh yeah and
I came next to you next to one of them
standing there yeah and he said they
said he said he was all nobody like sure
he said that - yeah so I was I know
buddy like shoot yeah and then he came
in my face it was like give me something
I was like you do something and then
someone came to took him away and then
you thought they need to come back I'm
gonna come back I'm gonna lose I'm gonna
mash up understand hours ago okay okay
so I guess it wasn't a good strike
because nothing really happened to you
so also another thing that happened is
he got arrested did you press charges to
be honest with you guys I forgave them
you know I didn't want to press charges
and this is because of my religion yeah
it teaches us forgiveness is the best
thing yeah we are told other charges in
the Koran that an eye for an eye what
that means is if somebody stops you you
have the right to slap them back yeah
okay but obviously when I live in an
Islamic state and also Allah does say is
better for you to forgive you so the
brother took he had two options he could
have easily say even the law of the land
if I'm not mistaken if someone is you
have a right to defend yourself you
didn't even go with the law of the land
and you went with unless want Allah says
that is better for you to forgive you so
this person so this person who's done
this it's a shame it shows his behavior
if this was a Muslim doing this it would
have gone viral so what we want to do is
be consistent if you're watching this if
you're watching this you saw this guy
get attacked yeah even though I know
people look at him be like this guy's
maybe he's an aggressive with his face
balaclava dog is the last thing people
expected from you looking like this that
therefore you might do something instead
it shows us not to judge a book by it's
cover because this man had mercy and
forgive the guy here so no no we're not
Christians anyway so that's why you guys
you watch the I want to keep it simple
watch the video for yourself right now
and see Steve said no wisdom got here
okay let's let's let's see in this
believe it here
okay see this believe one more favor
yes this is again now you guys might
understand when I set you guys are being
threatened and this is the why I put
barrel club on to cover my face for my
identity
yeah now you can believe it yeah because
this is April I was one of the people
who's been threatening me
we got the wheat here and obviously he
would have done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who raised the first time who raised the
first idea who raised the first don't
worry mate don't worry
I suppose them notes okay we get a
Muslim Geiger attack okay so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna let the footage
speak for so cuz that's all I need it
for me thank you Steve it was a pleasure
yeah